INTRO:
When we think of the most volatile assets
within the financial space, most of us think about
crypto. Despite reaching a market cap of over
$1 trillion, Bitcoin still experiences 70 to 80%
crashes on a regular basis. Within the crypto
markets, these are actually rather tame crashes
given what happens to certain altcoins like Luna.
Anyway, as you guys probably already know, Bitcoin
is currently experiencing one of these bear
markets having sold of 71% since November. The
most ironic part, however, is that Bitcoin has
actually held up better than some of the
most reputable and well known businesses
in the world such as Shopify. Since November,
Shopify is down 82.6%, and let’s not forget,
Shopify is not some penny stock or options
contract. They were the second biggest
ecommerce player in the world only beaten out by
Amazon. And at the peak, they were $228 billion,
but now, they’re only worth $38.5 billion. This
means that within 8 months, Shopify has lost $190
billion worth of maket cap. Now of course, you
could argue that the entire market is crashing,
and that’s true. But, to my knowledge, Shopify
is thus far the worst performing large cap
company in the world. So,
what happened to Shopify?
THE DROPSHIPPING BUBBLE:
One of the driving forces of Shopify over the
past few years has been the dropshipping bubble.
I mean, how many times have you heard
about teens making 6 if not 7 figures on
Shopify every year. And, let’s not forget about
all those dropshipping and Amazon FBA gurus on
YouTube. Now, I’m not trying to say that all of
these guys are scams or that dropshipping doesn’t
work. Dropshipping is absolutely a viable business
model and people who really know the business will
do well regardless of how competitive it gets.
With that being said though, the vast majority
of people who are getting into dropshipping
aren’t looking to start a series business.
A lot of them are trying to make some quick
money on the side, and this was especially true
at the beginning of the pandemic. In
April and May of 2020, the interest in
shopify literally doubled. And it wasn’t just
entrepreneurs that were interested in Shopify.
Investors were also quite intrigued by the idea.
Most investors didn’t want to start their own
stores or anything, but they were quick to
identify all of the extra interest heading
towards Shopify. And as hopeful entrepreneurs
piled on on the customer side, investors piled
on on the investor side, and it wasn’t long
till Shopify stock was sent to the moon.
From the pandemic bottom, Shopify stock would
grow nearly 500% within a matter of months.
While this likely felt super rewarding to Shopify
investors, this was also completely unsustainable.
Shopify’s PE ratio or price to earnings ratio
went to extreme levels of over 600. Now,
it should be noted that Shopify has historically
reinvested the vast majority of their profits,
so their net income is abnormally low which
skews their PE ratio, but this does not
apply to their PS ratio. Shopify’s PS ratio or
Price to Sales ratio also skyrocketed to 53.
To put that in perspective, even Tesla only had
a peak PS ratio of 24 meaning that according to
this metric, Shopify was valued twice as richly
as Tesla. Clearly, this was a hyper valuation
that was just waiting to crash, and that’s exactly
what would happen as the new interest in Shopify
fell off a cliff. Here’s the thing, most people
who try dropshipping don’t actually make it.
In fact, nearly 90% of dropshippers quit within
the first month after not making as much money
as they originally envisioned. This number
rises to 96% if we zoom out to the first 6
months of business. Out of the remaining 4%,
it’s likely that a good portion just continue
to treat dropshipping as a side business. They
might make 2 or 3 thousand dollars every month
which is great supplemental income, but not quite
enough to quit your job over especially given how
volatile dropshipping income can be. Considering
this, only about 1 to 2% of dropshippers
actually end up becoming long term customers
of Shopify who make them a lot of money. And
this becomes abundantly clear when we take
a look back at the google trends graph.
The new interest in Shopify died off as quickly as
it went up. And as the hype amongst entrepreneurs
died off, it was just a matter of time until
the hype amongst investors also died off.
AWFUL QUARTERS:
As new entreprenuer interest died off, it was only
natural that Shopify’s financials reflected that
sooner or later, and that’s exactly what’s been
happening over the past few quarters. Revenue and
profit growth has slowed down, and Shopify expects
these metrics to slow down even more in the coming
quarters. Hearing that, you’d probably think that
Shopify’s revenue was down 50% or something, but
that’s not actually the case. In fact, Shopify’s
12 month revenue and gross profit are still higher
than ever before. Not to mention, neither of these
metrics have ever gone down on a 12 month basis.
But, investors are fearful that Shopify is close
to posting their first year over year contraction.
If we take a closer look at Shopify’s year over
year growth in gross profit, you’ll see that this
growth rate is lower than we’ve ever seen. Shopify
has historically posted 80 to 90% growth quarter
after quarter, but today, this growth has dwindled
down to just 14%. Now, I know this makes a lot
of people in the comments quite frustrated
because it’s completely unrealistic to expect
that a company grows forever. 14% year over year
growth is still a great number from a fundamental
perspective. But the thing to keep in mind is
that the stock price had priced in over 50% annual
growth for years to come. So, a mere 14% was
simply not enough to appease investors. Something
else to note is that Shopify’s financials aren’t
as peachy when we take a look at their net income.
Shopify’s net income has never been particularly
high given that they just reinvest everything,
but since the end of 2020, Shopify’s net income
was finally starting to reach respectable levels
until the last 2 quarters. During these quarters,
Shopify lost $371 million and then $1.47 billion.
These losses can be traced back to
a couple of factors starting with
increasing operational expenses. Shopify is
spending significantly more across the board.
Sales and marketing has increased from
$186 million to $303 million. Research
and Development has increased from $175 million
to also $303 million. General and administrative
have increased from $67 million to $108 million.
And finally, transaction and loan losses have
increased from $10 million to $20 million. As you
can see, all of these operational categories have
increased by atleast 60%. Meanwhile, revenue has
only increased from $988 million to $1.203 billion
or roughly 21%. It seems that Shopify has yet to
account for diminishing growth, and that they’re
spending as if they were still growing at 70 to
80% per year. Aside from increasing operational
expenses, Shopify has also gotten destroyed
with their investments given that they’ve
mostly invested in hyper growth companies like
Affirm, Global-e, and Silvergate Capital which
are all down 70 to 90%. Such investments were the
driving factor behind Shopify’s external loses
of $1.55 billion last quarter which left
them with a horrendous quarterly report.
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES:
Aside from these superficial factors that are
affecting Shopify’s stock price and bottom line,
Shopify has a few fundamental issues as well
starting with dropshipping. Today, Shopify has
basically become synonymous with dropshipping,
and honestly, it’s probably where a significant
portion of their revenue comes from. But, Shopify
was never created to support dropshipping.
The purpose of Shopify was to make it easier for
small merchants to set up an online store. But,
dropshippers aren’t merchants at all. They’re
actually just marketers who route orders to
Ali express. This might not sound like a big
deal at first glance, but it is a big deal
for two reasons. First of all, people associate
Shopify with fake gurus and get rich schemes.
And secondly, the products that are sold on
Shopify are garbage quality because all the money
is being spent on marketing. Now, I’m not
against marketing by any means. Spending
20% of your revenue on getting new sales makes
perfect sense as a business. But, dropshippers
generally spend over 50% of the revenue on
marketing. If we have a $50 product for example,
this is usually how the breakdown goes. The
dropshipper spends $10 on the product itself,
they spend $30 on marketing, and then they
keep $10 for themselves. Because of this,
a $50 product from Shopify is usually not even
comparable to a $50 product from a physical
retailer in terms of quality and longevity,
and consumers are starting to notice. Recently,
I posted a video about how physical retailers
are making a comeback against online retailers,
and one of the top complaints that I saw in
the comment section was that goods from online
retailers are simply trash quality. This user
commented “I’d like to add that as of today,
on Amazon, most categories are flooded with the
same chinese low quality products but rebranded,
so for a lot of items it’s just quicker to find
them in a store”. And this guy was just talking
about Amazon. The quality problem is exponentially
worse on Shopify, and this is no doubt ruining
their brand image. One way that Shopify is trying
to move away from dropshipping is by growing their
own logistical services. They’re hoping that by
offering small businesses logistical capabilities,
they can attract higher quality clients. With
the help of Shopify, these small businesses
would finally have the opportunity to offer
shipping times and prices that are competitive
with Amazon and Walmart. The only problem with
this is that its basically just Amazon FBA.
The idea itself isn’t bad per se, and I’m not
really worried about Shopify being able to attract
enough customers. The real problem, however,
is that developing something like Amazon FBA
is extraordinarily expensive. I mean,
Amazon launched the FBA program in 2006,
and they’ve spent the past 16 years refining
every portion of the business. But despite this,
Amazon still posted an operational loss for
their retail business last quarter. So, clearly,
if Shopify doubles down on logistics, they’re not
going to be posting sizable profits anytime soon
meaning that the stock may still
have a lot of room to the downside.
THE FUTURE OF SHOPIFY:
I know this video has been extremely negative
towards Shopify, but I don’t want to give off
the impression that Shopify is struggling per se.
Yes, their stock price has gotten obliterated and
they’re experiencing some painful quarters due to
rising operational expenses and some large write
offs . But, in the grand scheme of things, Shopify
is still an ecommerce giant and they are the go
to service for creating online stores. With that
being said though, a lot of their growth in recent
years has come from dropshipping which is not
the best for their long term business. After all,
I don’t think Shopify wants to be
an American gateway to Ali express.
Their real goal is to become small merchants’ best
friend, and that’s exactly what they’re trying to
do with their logistical services. But this is
by no means a small undertaking, and it’ll take
several years for such a plan to produce returns.
In the meantime, Shopify will likely post little
to no profits. And in our current risk off market,
that’s basically a death sentence and I wouldn’t
be surprised if Shopify ends up selling off 90-95%
before finally bottoming. If you’re willing to
hold through this potential short term volatility
however, Shopify will likely be a phenomenal
investment 10 years down the line, but that’s just
what I think and it’s not financial advice. Are
you guys a fan of dropshipping? Comment that down
below. Also, drop a like if you wish that online
products weren’t garbage quality. And of course
consider joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.